I'm gonna cry
this is the hardest interview I've ever
done in my entire no for real hi I'm
Madison Bailey I'm Drew Starkey I'm
Madeline Klein I'm Austin North hi my
name is carlacia Grant I'm Jonathan
Davis and I'm Chase Stokes and we're the
cast of Outer Banks and this is the best
day of my life
spoiler alert if you haven't watched the
season do that first and then come back
cool bring on the puppies
oh my God
I'm going on the stomach
I'm sorry
oh no how do you help
chunky monkey
and we're supposed to like do stuff
after this if there's questions can we
do them later
it was how can you ask me questions
right now when there's this beautiful
little beast right here we get to film
in in Barbados the beautiful country of
Barbados the people that are so
welcoming and it's it's gorgeous
food was awesome not to mention just the
the amazing people there and the amazing
Barbadian crew being able to actually
like experience the the locations and
like really feel it out there is like
it's very different than like being on a
green screen
[Music]
[Laughter]
nobody's here right Maddie what's your
favorite
I feel like we shot two different
seasons I feel like we shot the season
we filmed in Charleston and we shot the
season we filmed in Barbados and they're
all going to cut together I think the
the kind of the joy of Outer Banks is
there's never really one singular moment
because it's just kind of like summer
camp all the time for six months out of
the year we get to do this
I am in love with you please don't leave
it's pretty gnarly rave's haircut yeah
it's pretty big I think rape uh melting
the cross was was kind of an insane one
too it's kind of like a really evil
thing of course it's rape so you know he
does evil things but like just like that
was intense I'm having such a hard time
focusing this is right listen this one's
coming home with me
I auditioned for Steve Harrington
when they rebooted Star Wars my first
audition ever in La was for John boyega
as well really and I was so scared that
I sat in the bathroom for like two hours
I also auditioned for um Michael's role
in All American and also Jamal and on my
black so I don't really know what
category I fit into I auditioned for
John B unsurprisingly did not get it I
actually auditioned to play um shoot in
Outer Banks
huh like soup like Deputy Deputy shoot
calling I didn't that's my first time
hearing that how did you think that a
secret for that yeah I just cleared out
all my files and I was like oh
[Laughter]
It's Gonna Keep that part quiet I'm
gonna respects people's privacy Amanda
Seyfried messaged me I was pretty
excited about that Luca doncia if he's a
big fan of the show Madeline Klein dmed
me once no way
Rihanna The Rock she should be a part of
Leo you know they're both Island girls
Danny DeVito
I want these dogs to have a cameo
they're the most famous people I've ever
been around
would you play I play shoot I would play
topper
I really would you have such a fun role
I feel that about you I would love to
play Kiara yes I would want to be Barry
he seems like every day he comes to work
he's having a good time I feel like I
want to be JJ yeah or Kiara both of them
rape would be an interesting kind of
role to take on it's like a psychopath I
played Sarah Cameron just so I know what
it's like to be loved
[Music]
he answered this
um I had an inkling in the back of my
head that there was always going to be a
reunion but to see it come to life and
to come to fruition and then the ways
that it kind of takes shape this season
was a lot of fun to navigate because
it's such a tricky slope of what do you
do where does that Line in the Sand of
when when family is thicker than blood
and I think that's what this season is
all about realizing that sometimes the
people that are closest to you are not
necessarily the ones that are actually
family and John B has to go through some
hoops to figure that out that's for sure
big Hoops kiss this guy's face dude
right come here dude have a great time
I'm gonna put you on my legs and I'm
gonna hold you like a little newborn
baby
[Music]
stop but yeah that's about as far as my
attention span can go with puppies
[Music]
and also just our regular dinner parties
it is quite a pinchwy moment getting uh
drunk with your Heroes this is insane
it's ridiculous this is so distracting
[Applause]
more of our slang has made it in this
season than probably any season of the
show we have a lot of like little
phrases that we say off camera in our
own little personal life that always end
up finding their spots in the show and
then we'll tell Jonas and the writers
afterwards that there's like a hidden
meaning to it so I know I know it's so
good and I think that's just a testament
to like the chemistry that we build and
the way these writers have kind of seen
us grow you took a tumble sir
it's a good time I think the two
characters have a lot of commonalities
the free-spirited the lifestyle that
both characters want to live is pretty
similar
[Music]
you know I'm a new person so they're
really great I'm like welcoming in and
making sure I know things and giving me
great advice hazing me sometimes we
won't talk about that but you know it's
all about you got to go through freshman
woes
[Music]
we get to film in season three on this
Lighthouse which I'm excited for
everybody to see it was very hard to get
to yes and a lot of uh long-term
planning to get there but I think that
was a really fun scene I don't think
anyone's seen it yet but nope
ship is incredible he's he kind of set
the tone I think on set for for a lot of
us three years ago we all came in we
were pretty wide-eyed and kind of wild
and Chip was a good kind of reference
point on how to uh be professional and
show up knowing your lines and I've
learned a lot from it
theories on the internet I think that
John B bandana one and that being the
shroud of the Cross is the funniest one
to me obviously John B gets hurt pretty
pretty consistently but I'm always
healed this is the hardest interview
I've ever done in my entire no for real
foreign
just by chance filming in Serbia at the
same time and it was right after season
two had come out didn't realize how big
the show was in the Balkan it was a lot
of love but it was it was pretty intense
pretty crazy shout out to Serbia shout
out to Serbia Belgrade yes the Hilton
the Hilton
Andor so good I um thanks much from
scratch Game of Thrones Love Island
what do you mean do you watch somebody
yeah and Kaleidoscope too yeah I just
started Kaleidoscope do you guys want to
be on Outer Banks like it's thought
about tomorrow and on this note it's a
wrap it's nap time
thank you BuzzFeed for having us make
sure you guys watch Outer Banks season
trays and all these puppies
we may take
fast these two might be coming home with
me yes this one's gone okay
okay
[Music]